yeah absolutely so I'm Joe Dolan er I am
one of the founders of pachyderm which
if you haven't heard of pachyderm isn't
absolutely fine they're only two people
in that company um but but I will ask
does anybody know what a pachyderm is
show of hands who's who's heard the word
pachyderm okay so these are all
pachyderms
and all you have to do to be a pachyderm
is be a mammal and have thick skin
that's a that's actually all the
classification means and we we named our
company after this because we think that
packet herbs are pretty cool animals in
because Hadoop has a pachyderm it RS has
a pachyderm which is an elephant as
their mascot so um in the past when I've
given talks like this there's almost
always been a ton of questions and
that's just made to talk that much
better so we should absolutely try to do
the same thing if you have a question
just please let me know and we will
we'll try to get answered as possible so
thinking with pipelines um given that
this is a data engineering talk I
probably don't need to explain to you
that like when you've got just some data
on your local machine it's really really
quick to like write a Python script to
analyze the data right this is super
simple this right here is a script that
does some Bayesian learning on chess
games which is sort of one of the big
demos we've done with a pachyderm the
last few months so scripts are super
easy and just to get everyone on the
same page let's talk about why they're
so easy they run locally right so you
can just run them and a few seconds
later you see if they worked and if
there's an error you just get a trace
back right there so it's really really
easy to develop and you know what data
is going into them because this is
literally reading from standard in and I
know how to handle that and if I want to
change that data I can just grab stuff
out these tools are very simple to
understand and lastly I know the
environment that they're running in
because it's my machine right I can
install whatever library I want that's
not a problem however there's a limit to
how much you can do with a script
because there's a limit to how much data
you
fit on a single machine and if you get
past that limit then your only choice is
to go the cluster go to some sort of a
cluster Hadoop just there's lots of
sequel databases that do this there's
lots of options but unless lastly the
thing about scripts is are super easy to
share right because I can just pass this
script around and you know it basically
I can give it to somebody it's just a
simple text file but in a cluster this
gets really really hard right code
dependency management becomes a really
big issue because I don't necessarily
know what environment this is going to
run in and if I want to use something
like a Bayesian learning machine
learning library like I was using right
there I need to make sure that the right
cot the right version of psych head is
installed I need to make sure it's the
same on all of the different machines in
the cluster which is a nightmare data
dependency management gets a lot harder
too because I can't just you know find
data on my machine which I understand
really well and check to make sure it's
the right stuff with CAD I need to like
find it in HDFS or something right
and lastly it gets a lot harder to
collaborate because there's no simple
way to represent this as like a text
file like I came with a script I can't
just email this whole pipeline to my
friend there's like State spread spread
across a job tracker spread across a
bunch of things so in this talk we're
going to talk about a way to sort of
simplify this process and way to think
about this problem differently that can
maybe fix it and that way is pipelines
so show of hands who uses pipelines and
some or something that they would call a
pipeline in their work what are your
pipelines look like
mmm-hmm don't be ashamed that's what
everyone's pipelines look like what are
your pipelines look like it's a lot of
sorry okay very cool works so there's a
lot of different ways to represent these
things um and it winds up getting very
fractured and but we can all sort of
agree on what the basic concept of what
a pipeline is right it's a way of
describing this computational cluster
and ideally what you're trying to get
back to is the simplicity of that script
except in a cluster and that's useful
because in the best case these pipelines
can get you back the reproducibility um
and maybe not for the pipeline's that
you were talking about here but for some
cases and then in the implementation
that I'm going to show you you can test
them locally on you can test them on a
local machine before you run them on the
cluster yes
so in cluster I just mean sort of the
general idea of I have some some set of
machines outside that I can do
distributed computation on versus my
local machine that's just right here and
I can see what's on it right and I have
like sort of complete control over this
system no so oftentimes oftentimes a lot
of the reason that this is hard is
because like the person developing the
pipeline is a data scientist and then
the person running the machines is it is
sort of like an infrastructure person I
actually have some sort of direct
experience of this being the
infrastructure person and probably maybe
twenty-five to thirty percent of the
time that I spent was just servicing
requests or like hey I wrote this script
that does that does processing it works
locally but like I run this on the
cluster and the versions wrong and just
going to install that was really really
hard so that's that's sort of what I
mean by that dichotomy questions good um
and lastly and the really really
interesting feature about this is um it
would be nice if we could collaborate on
pipelines as simply as we collaborate on
code so
pachyderm is a new system that my
company is building that is sort of
entirely based on pipelines that's
that's the core primitive that we think
of as computation and this actually is
what a pipeline looks looks like to us
um really the data in the in the github
repo is the pipeline but the thing
that's worth noting about this is that
it's entirely text base based this this
github repo is a completely portable
pipeline for this that you can run on
various clusters so you can you know
share pipelines between companies you
can very easily download them you can
run this locally and it runs the same in
every single place and so it's much much
easier to collaborate on this and so I'm
gonna point out a few of a few of the
core things that go into the pipeline um
into this repo there's a folder with
data in it right and that actually just
contains sort of a a down sampling of
the data that you should expect to find
in the cluster when you run this that's
really important because that means that
you can have scripts that just test it
right and you can see if this thing is
going to break when you do it because if
you don't have something like that then
you can write a broken script and only
found that find out an hour later that
it's broken and that really slows down
your data scientists when they have to
do stuff like that um it has an image
folder and this is sort of where all of
the magic is contained the image folder
actually is is something that we can
compile into a docker image um and
that's it that's how we get around the
code dependency problem um and then it
has a job folder that describes what's
in them and so it should be noted that
this pipeline spec it exists if we have
an implementation of it but as a very
it's very much an alpha so going going
through each of these which folder uh
whoever uses docker in their workplace
how do you use docker
nice
another hand there okay you have you
have a sort of an ops guy that packages
up stuff so Duggar is sort of the tool
that allows us to do what we do with
these pipelines right the the whole goal
here of reproducibility docker does that
for code all by itself we sort of we
provide the data part of that and so
docker lets you take libraries in your
code and everything and package them up
into this bundle that's going to run the
same anywhere and so if you take this
side kit and stuff like that and compile
that into a docker container your data
scientists can know that his code is
that ran locally and worked is going to
be identical in the cluster so that's
that's the image folder um next we have
the job folder and this is actually um
this this speaks to the data dependency
aspect of this problem so when you're
running a script locally um you can pipe
data in from anywhere and you can pipe
data in from other scripts right you can
pipe it in from outside sources but
that's sort of you knowing how to run it
and if you want a pipe if you want to
give this to a person in a way that they
can understand in a way that they can
run that information needs to come with
it so in this implementation our
pipeline basically is this dag a
directed acyclic graph that involves all
of the dependencies of how data needs to
flow through this system so the
computation can be completed and
basically this this defines the data
flow and then each of these actual
transformations on data the nodes in the
dag those are commands that will get
executed within the docker container and
lastly we have the data and install
directories the data directory as I said
is sort of designed to give testability
to this and the the install scripts are
sort of just like they're like the make
files they send it to different backends
so right now that pipeline that you saw
there you can run it locally you can run
it on a pachyderm cluster and ideally in
the future we'd like this to support
other backends we'd like this to be sort
of a
common spec and we're hoping it can be
simple enough to do that so any
questions on this notion of a pipeline
yes
um so so what sorry absolutely so the
question is what's special about docker
as a VM um so docker definitely has a
very clear advantage over like a
standard VM like like VirtualBox or
something and that advantage really
comes down to just speed honestly you
can sort of kick off a docker process
and it takes like only a little bit
longer than kicking off a process just
on your machine locally versus you know
booting up a VM is in my experience like
minimum of 15 seconds so um the other
real advantage that it has actually is
just sort of the the momentum behind the
project right like a lot of a lot of
people know it you have a lot of stuff
that you can do you can just like pull
in a docker container for a lot of
independent purposes and it's just like
they're ready for you to use and so that
comes in really handy any other
questions
okay so so this is this is my definition
of pipelines pipelines are great and now
I'm going to give you sort of um one one
more example to show you how cool this
really is so a pipeline gives us a very
very rigorous way of defining how data
flows through a system in pachyderm we
have a replacement for HDFS which is
called PFS the pachyderm file system and
the pachyderm file system has this very
nice feature which is that it's entirely
differ
basically and so if you're familiar with
git right at any time and in your when
you're using git you can see a dip of
how all of your data has changed right
so if you can see a dip of how
everything has changed and you know how
data flows through everything then you
can automatically detect what to do
based on change data to sort of rerender
your results right and what this means
is that when just a little bit more data
comes in you can almost instantly see
what your map what your pipeline would
look like if it were run on the
entire data set right and this is
something that you really can't do with
modern systems at least you can't do
without a lot of work to like
specifically prepare for like streaming
but if you have if you have a rigorous
definition of a pipeline and you have a
rigorous def and you have a rigorous
understanding of how the data has
changed then there really isn't a strong
distinction between streaming and batch
processing anymore and that is that is
one of the many very cool distinctions
of this that's actually sort of the
entirety of the content I have that may
a bit a bit short but I would love I
would love to take more questions yeah
sure
yeah so in terms of implementation um
our file system builds on top of better
FS has anybody ever read there's a
wonderful blog post called who needs get
when you have ZFS that well so if you
haven't read that that blog post I
totally recommend you read it but
basically what that blog post describes
is how you can take in this case a ZFS
but better FS is sort of feature
equivalent to ZFS at this point how you
can take ZFS and implement everything
that get has in terms of your file
system right and it gives you sort of
these snapshots that are the same as
commits and you can actually have an
equivalent of pushing and pulling
because it will like replicate these
file systems to each other so our file
system is actually just a distributed
layer on top of better FS to let you get
these gets like semantics in a
distributed setting and so what you what
you get for this though is really really
cool because it actually is really
useful to add feature to have when
you're doing distributed processing in a
file system um pretty to give you an
example of what's really nice about this
one of the problems that we faced all
the time at Airbnb was that we would
sort of give our data scientists some
data to work with it'd be somewhere in
HDFS but like they'd all be pointing at
the same folder because we didn't want
to make copies of it and then one of
them was just sort of think oh like well
this data is like got some anomaly in it
that I want to clean out and he would
fix that data but then that would break
someone else's computations and was all
a big mess and in the worst case we just
give everyone a different copy of it
which was really really expensive in
pachyderm you can actually just give
everybody a branch and those are
incredibly lightweight those are like as
lightweight as get branches and so you
can use those or just like throw away
like you use those for every single
experiment you do does it replace
pointers um you mean like sort of leaps
yeah yeah absolutely so it has it has a
notion of links so the tricky thing
about links in a distributed file system
setting is that if you want to be able
to like access something by name right
like I want to I want to be able to say
like get the file foo then I need to
have some notion of where to talk of who
to talk to
file system and so the way you would
have to implement is that is something
in the name note um
that's sort of a little bit tricky given
our architecture because we actually
don't have a name node but what that can
work really well for is you can use
links to sort of remap things for when
you do distributed processing on them
because there when it's an aggregation
you're already talking to every single
node so you don't actually care about
that routing problem you just sort of
think of like oh this is a file that's
in this folder here and this folder here
and so do that um doing doing links in
such a way that you could do random
accesses like is a little bit trickier
yeah
um so in our system you can sort of um
you can control this a little bit so you
can like chain them right to each other
or you can have them like right out to
the file system in between and a lot of
times you you sort of want to do that
differently depending on how you're
running it like you might want to run it
in a debug mode where you write
everything out intermittently because
that will help you debug a problem where
like the data looks wrong on over here
but you don't know which script is
responsible for that but yeah I mean in
the sort of the most efficient when what
you care about is efficiency then yeah
they just pass it straight to each other
can I run it right now I can certainly
try
let me see let me get my bearings for a
second
so anima yes or a memory has faded if I
was doing if I was doing demos and I
said no but that turned out not to be
the case here we go okay now this should
work so this is sort of talking through
what I'm doing so I'm not typing code
and saying nothing um basically what
this is doing is this is rebuilding um
this is redoing packet rebuilding
pachyderm and then launching it in a
local single cluster node and
so now according to docker I have
pachyderm up and running there and now
I'm switching over to the chess repo
over here where I have a script that
will run it locally and so what that did
is you can see is it copied in a bunch
of games and actually why don't I even
just show you what one of these looks
like
so this is I don't know if we have any
chess players in the crowd but this is
sort of the standard notation people use
to describe games this right here is
like metadata this this was first this
game is a game from 1475 actually so and
it's 17 moves long and it looks like
white wins this game so there are a
bunch of games like that in there and
right now if I look well
there should there should be processes
of what I look at top there should be
chess engines running but they're not
for some reason and sorry yeah this is I
just ran that directly from from sort of
our our next like bleeding edge branch
that probably something I'm not thinking
of that's broken right now
um no so so just so just to sort of
distinguish here there's there's two
types of docker containers that are
running there's the PFS containers like
the one that I spun up that you see when
I type docker PS that one is very
long-running it isn't it isn't one per
node we actually schedule these using
core OS and that gives us this very very
nice abstraction layer where we can just
say we want like three copies of every
single shard and it will figure out how
to map those on to the physical machines
that we have and if a machine dies it
will actually take the things that we're
on that machine and put them on to other
machines that are still alive that it
can get in contact with the other dot
way we use docker containers is for the
actual pipeline notes um and they're
each pipeline right now defines a single
docker container and we can actually
sort of run multiple commands within the
same one there's a couple of different
ways to run this but the one that we're
actually using here is creating a web
server within the docker container and
so basically what it's doing is it spins
up a container and then it's posting in
chess games and our server takes those
fires off the analysis process and then
returns the results of that and in the
body of the response um so there are
there are definitely well they're
definitely 100 more efficient ways to do
messaging um in terms of sort of
something that a lot of people can write
to right like like a single script that
you can like deploy a container and have
a way to push a bunch of data through it
that's sort of a very low barrier of
entry way to do it which is the reason
that we picked that first
these sort of the actual sort of optimal
efficiency way is that we stop even
thinking in terms of a function that
gets like each value out of the file
system and we actually just give you
direct access to the underlying file
system and so there you'll get all of
the data at once and you sort of have to
map this into the resulting file system
that's a lot less safe right but you can
do that super super fast because you can
sort of access it however you want you
can you know do all sorts of
optimizations there yes
mm-hmm ah yeah it being core OS and more
specifically um fleet is sort of their
scheduler and so yeah fleet fleet is the
thing that lets us speak in the
high-level language of like we won like
just this many copies of the schedule
somewhere in the cluster
um there's sort of a cut there are a
couple of things that do this right now
that are all like kind of gaining steam
there's like mais O's there's fleet
there's kubernetes probably a few other
ones I'm not thinking of and we sort of
eventually hope to support all of these
but core OS at least at the time when we
started the project seemed like the the
highest like the best ratio of ease of
starting to like how good it was
so
so in terms of what the actual like
logic is that's in the image yeah and
yeah it should be up-to-date and should
run yeah but as we as we found out here
you know that's it's possible that
there's there's a bugs and if so please
please submit them or email them and I
will I'll try to make sure thanks guys